okay
the journey was so dangerous in my life
I will never try that again
[Music]
I thought I was going to a hero
and then all of a suddenly I found
myself
here in Brazil at Espirito Santos
Victoria
[Music]
so I live by the Highlands
I looked
at their foreign verses coming
so I decided
if I have an opportunity
eventually
I don't care
to know where they are taking you
through
nothing is not work for you you have to
have something for me the economy is not
working for me everything is not working
for me and then
before I came here I was homeless
no home you know you know my family my
wife is staying in another place where I
am staying my children you know so I
just have to make up my mind
[Music]